where did you like at what point in time
did you reach your break because you had
said earlier that you had already you
had already reached your breaking point
with joe but you would kind of
okay i'm going to give it one more go
when did you initially reach that
breakup point with joe well
royce
wanted everybody to come to heaven and
detroy this studio
and do
some joints for glasshouse and um
um
we all
scheduled it
said i will be there
you know this was some years ago too
and
i flew out there
and i was the only one that showed up
wow
you see i'm saying
and
i'm like what what's going on where's
everybody out so i called joelle where
are you at
he's like oh crook man you down there i
should have called you before you jumped
on the plane joe told me he wasn't going
so i just i didn't get on the plane i
figure if he's not going well it's
wasted
and i said but why did he say that and
he was like he's like i don't know he
just said he wasn't going
at the last minute and i was like wow so
now here i am in detroit it's it's
snowing like a [ __ ] it's cold as
[ __ ] and i'm standing outside smoking a
[ __ ] cigar with [ __ ]
snowflakes on my beard and [ __ ] like
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do now so me
and royce ended up doing like nine to
ten joints ourselves
just
using the time to create you know what i
mean as long as we might never hear
songs you might not ever hear you know
what i mean and uh
that was it for me on my plane ride back
i was like you know what i'm never doing
this
i'm not doing this
with that type of energy and
i was only willing like i said
for rice and
funny enough
you know i know i know how royce feels
i'm very considerate of other people's
feelings
but sometimes you gotta consider your
own feelings and it was time for me to
shut down shop and
move on